avec un nouveau président
[Musique]
les animaux fantastiques 2 les crimes de
grain d'aile valdes sort le 14 novembre
et je pense qu'il est temps de vous
proposer un trois théories mais avant
toute chose nous devons poser quelques
bases
il y a des choses à savoir sur cette
saga écrite par jk rowling je pense que
beaucoup savent déjà mais un rappel ne
fait pas de mal les animaux fantastiques
est une saga de cinq films qui se
déroule sur dix neuf années entre 1926
et 1945
alors oui norbert dragon's au en est le
personnage principal
mais la saga ne va pas réellement dans
ce sens nous sommes dans une saga qui
évoque la sombre époque de la montée en
puissance de grindelwald et donc par
liaison de l'histoire de dumbledore le
premier volet poser les bases et nous
présenter jacob china dragon's haut et
j'en passe mais les choses sérieuses
vont réellement commencé à partir du 14
novembre avec le second opus dumbledore
était amoureux de crime bellwald il
voulait tout de remodeler le monde à
leur image
bien que les idéaux de greendale valdes
était plus sombre que ce que pensaient
dumbledore
enfin bref je ne vous cache pas que les
théories que je vous ai trouvé et/ou
imaginez bien qu'elle soit en rapport
avec le monde des animaux fantastiques
qui traite plus des origines de la saga
on ne va pas s'attarder plus longtemps
attaquons les théories
[Musique]
pour ouvrir le bal nous allons parler
des origines de nagui ni le serpent du
seigneur des ténèbres
car il se pourrait que les animaux
fantastiques de nous l'introduisent si
nous nous intéressons au trailer du
second opus nous remarquons que le film
se déroulera particulièrement à paris et
qu'il introduira le circle magique
arcanes us ou croyances ferait la
rencontre d'une femme très particulière
cette femme serait ce qu'on appelle un
mâle et dictus c'est une malédiction par
le sens qu'un individu peut être en
possession
en gros si vous l'avez plus le temps
passe plus la personne se transforme en
animal jusqu'à devenir véritablement
cette femme qui semble se lier à
croyances vient de ce cirque et en
serait une attraction majeure appelé la
femme serpent dans le premier volet sur
une affiche
cette femme pourrait être réellement
nagini le serpent horcruxes de voldemort
avec il noue un lien très puissant le
design des vêtements de la femme n'est
pas anodin nous remarquons très
clairement un côté reptiles sur ce
qu'elle porte et plus le temps passe
plus elle devient serpent jusqu'à
devenir certainement nagini après tout
pourrait coller à la perfection
nous allons en parler dans les théories
suivante mais la saga des animaux
fantastiques se déroule lors de la
naissance de voldemort jusqu'à la fin de
ses études soit de 1926 à 1945
nous allons très certainement avoir des
origines sur le seigneur des ténèbres et
ceux qui l'entourent
d'où vient nagini et d'où vient ce lien
si puissant qui les unit la réponse est
forcément dans les futurs films nagini
et d'eau et de pensée et de parole avec
voldemort
ces deux derniers communiquent entre eux
enfourche langues et nagini part même en
mission d'infiltration our voldemort au
ministère de la magie
elle est même capable d'appeler son
maître comme un mangemort et elle lui
montre une fidélité sans faille
on peut même distinguer le fait que
nagui niçois la chose qui compte le plus
aux yeux de voldemort
elle est le premier hors krux du
seigneur des ténèbres et son seul et
véritable ami en quelque sorte
chronologiquement parlant ça pourrait
largement arriver il n'y a pas grand
chose à rajouter mais surtout à
découvrir car si c'est vrai le
background serait énorme
[Musique]
cette théorie est un petit peu longue
laissez moi tout d'abord vous rappeler
ce qu'est un obscur us pour faire simple
un obscur us est une sorte de monstre se
développant dans le corps de jeunes
enfants sorciers qui rejettent leurs
pouvoirs croyances bien qu'il soit une
exception à la règle
par rapport à son âge en est le parfait
exemple depuis son plus jeune âge
croyances fut battue par sa mère
d'adoption qui rejetait totalement
l'existence de la magie mes croyances
est un sorcier il peut maîtriser la
magie bien qu'il n'en a pas réellement
conscience il est bloqué par sa mère
adoptive qui lui fait connaître que la
souffrance et la peur ce blocage de ne
pas maîtriser la magie qu'il devrait
maîtriser a créé en lui ce qu'on appelle
un obscur us une créature dhombres qui
est toute la souffrance et la colère
confiné puis rejetés à cause de ce
reniement de la magie et donc croyance
en est devenu l'hôte ce qu'on appelle un
obscur yal mais contrairement à ce
dernier la puissance d'un obscur russe
est tel que l'obscur yal qui le contient
ne peut passer l'âge de 10 ans du moins
normalement bref maintenant si nous nous
tournons vers l'histoire d'albus
dumbledore nous savons qu'il avait un
frère et une soeur à belfort étaient
présents dans la saga d'harry potter est
connu par tous il était très méfiant de
son frère et l'accusé d'avoir sacrifié
sa soeur dans sa quête de pouvoir
et justement connaissez vous réellement
ariana dumbledore ariana fut la soeur
cadette de la famille dumbledore est
celle qui l'a détruisit en quelque sorte
lors de son jeune âge ariana fut très
malmené par trois moldus qu'il avait vu
pratiquer de la magie cette attaque va
énormément dégrader la vie de la jeune
fille qui sera totalement coupés du
monde extérieur après avoir déménagé à
godric's hollow avec sa famille pour
échapper aux problèmes et accessoirement
échapper d'envoyer la jeune enfant à
l'hôpital de saintes mangouste et c'est
ici que la théorie commence à entrer en
jeu
perceval dumbledore le père des trois
enfants se vengera détroit moldus ayant
attaqué méchamment safig et sera
malencontreusement envoyé à ce cas ben
ariana isolé du monde suite à cette
attaque face aux moldus commencera à
perdre sa santé mentale avec de
nombreuses crises de colère de maux de
tête et j'en passe ce traumatisme
cet accident a totalement fait perdre à
ariana dumbledore le contrôle de ses
pouvoirs magiques et c'est lors d'une de
ces furieuses crises de colère car y'a
nature a sans le vouloir sa mère kendra
dumbledore laissant alors les deux
frères aînés s'occuper de leurs soeurs
pour la théorie
ariana présente exactement les symptômes
de la création d'un obscur russes ces
dernières a subi un sévère traumatisme
face à l'attack qu'elle a subis elle
renie a donc ses pouvoirs qui au final
laurent du hors de contrôle
tout comme croyance à l'époque
malheureusement cette dernière fut tué
lors d'une altercation entre les deux
frères dumbledore et greendale valdes à
cette époque dumbledore passé énormément
de temps avec grindelwald dans leur
quête de remodeler le monde
et acquérir plus de pouvoir grâce aux
reliques de la mort c'est abel forte qui
voulaient résonner son frère à propos de
grindelwald et qu'ils ne devaient pas
négliger sa soeur ariana gay laërt le
prix comme une attaque et un violent
combat opposant les trois sorciers
éclata c'est alors que la jeune arianna
arriva au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
cette dernière se prit un sort perdu qui
la tue a instantanément à belfort tu as
toujours accusé depuis son frère d'être
le principal acteur de cet accident mais
il est quand même plus supposer que ce
soit grindelwald qui je talent sort en
tout cas ceux ci a grandement éloignée
les deux amis et grindelwald s'en est
allé évidemment tout ceci on le sait
déjà
mais le fait qu ariane à dumbledore soit
un obscur yal révèlerait beaucoup de
choses grindelwald a été témoin de la
puissance d'un obscur yal et que
cherche-t-il dans le premier opus des
animaux fantastiques à contrôler
croyances évidemment galère grindelwald
aurait pu se mettre à la recherche d'un
obscur yal pour faciliter sa montée au
pouvoir en le manipulant cela
expliquerait son grand intérêt profond
pour croyances enfin si nous nous
intéressons aux déclarations de jk
rowling ces dernières trouvent les idées
des fans très intéressante mais qu'elle
ne veut pas y répondre pour le moment
sous peine de gâcher plusieurs intrigues
ceci prouve encore une fois
l'intelligence et le génie de
l'écrivaine qui a tout prévu dans les
moindres détails
dumbledore in grindelwald sont liés leur
histoire ne sera pas négligé en cette
saga
loin de là
alors pour cette dernière théorie
j'aimerais vous parler d'un événement
qui risquent d'intervenir vers les
derniers épisodes de la saga animaux
fantastiques
si certains ne le savaient pas norbert
dragon's eau est déjà connu dans
l'univers d'harry potter dans les années
de celui qui a survécu face à voldemort
effectivement norbert et l'écrivain des
livres du jeune sorcier lors de ses
études il est présent aussi en tant que
portrait dans le bureau de dumbledore
simple clin d'oeil car normalement seuls
les directeur de poudlard ont leur
portrait accroché
enfin il est présent sur la carte du
maraudeur à un certain moment c'est
aussi un autre clin d'oeil proposé par
les créateurs tout ceci pour montrer que
norbert drago est encore très connu à
cette époque
certainement grâce à deux belles d'or
est justement ce dernier serait
intervenu une fois de plus
mais cette fois ci dans l'histoire
d'hagrid jk rowling avait forcément tout
prévu dans harry potter et la chambre
des secrets nous faisons la rencontre d'
aragog une accro menthe hulk hagrid a en
sa possession
cette araignée sera l'objet d'un conflit
qui entraînera hagrid as cabane car tom
jedusor le futur seigneur des ténèbres
avait justement fait croire que la
chrome en tulle était le monstre de la
chambre des secrets et cagre il l'avait
réveillée alors que bien évidemment il
n'en était rien et c'était bien objet du
sort qui avait ouvert la chambre est
réveillé le basilic étant le dernier
héritier de salazar serpentard cependant
si nous nous tournons vers l'histoire
d'aragon
même sans avoir besoin des livres il est
mentionné dans les films kara gogh a été
amené dans la poche d'un voyageur puis a
été donnée à hagrid un voyageur qui est
en possession d'une espèce d'araignée
rare et qu'on ne trouve pas à poudlard
qui en plus a voyagé avec dans sa poche
évidemment on parle bien de norbert
dragon's au norbert serait celui qui
amena aragog à hagrid certainement en
échange de quelque chose afin de le
remercier ou peu importe ceux ci je
pense n'est pas anodin car hagrid semble
réellement admirer norbert
et qu'est ce qui me fait dire ceci
rappelez-vous d'harry potter à l'école
des sorciers
hagrid est en possession d'un oeuf de
dragon et je précise que c'est un oeuf
ii d'aragon
quand l'oeuf a éclos agri lui donnera le
nom de norbert sans la moindre
hésitation
norbert le dragon norbert le bébé dragon
norbert drago no vous me suivez
de plus il faut savoir que la saga des
animaux fantastiques se situe entre 1926
et 1945 donc une saga s'étendant sur dix
neuf années et que se passe-t-il en 1926
lors du premier volet des animaux
fantastiques et bien tom jedusor vient
de naître
c'est lors de la fin des années 30 qui
le dénonça hagrid pour la chambre des
secrets
donc si on situ ceci par rapport à la
saga j'estimerai environ vers le
quatrième film
attendez-vous certainement avoir ceci
arrive et tout n'est que théorique
encore mais ses limites sur la saga des
animaux fantastiques va apporter du très
lourd dans l'univers d'harry potter et
m'emballe encore plus que la saga
d'origine je fais totalement confiance à
jk rowling et j'espère reparler de la
saga très bientôt
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo si l'envié vous en prend vous
pouvez vous abonner à ma chaîne laisser
un pouce bleu ou me suivre sur twitter
j'ai également un outil psy vous
souhaitez m'aider financièrement en
regardant quelques publicités 7 et argo
rock et que le live earth soit avec vous
[Musique]